seven months have passed since the green
poison outbreak and the events that
unfolded in New York City division
agents have continued on with their
mission of saving what remains across
the United States when suddenly their
lifeline the civet the SH D Network the
backbone of their advanced technology
and communications ghost did quickly
followed by the backup protocol of a
distress call that summons all agents to
the nation's capital Washington DC
[Music]
[Music]
agents from outside of DC make the way
to the capital fighting through the city
they come across what remains of the
city's Joint Task Force who have set up
their base of operations in the White
House shd coordinators on-site filling
the agents of what's happening
throughout the city three hostile
factions are fighting for control the
hyenas a group that is composed of
several gangs who have come together as
one under the leadership of a council to
take advantage of the chaos that is
unfolding the outcasts a group made up
of survivors from the Roosevelt Island
quarantine zone the goal to enact
revenge on those responsible for the
mistreatment in to the society that
allowed it to happen and the true sons a
powerful group of ex jtf who have lost
faith in the government's ability bring
control to the situation at hand the
division agents get to work finding the
fault to restore the sh t network but
before they can achieve this new
information comes to light somewhere in
the city
they may in fact be a cure to the virus
that starved at all but also that the
previously assumed did President Ellis
may have survived the crash via force
one while clearing out areas throughout
the city the agents find Intel and
Alice's whereabouts and that he's been
held captive by the hyenas the division
managed to clear the hostiles and
extract him via helicopter back at the
White House
Ellis confirms that there is in fact a
cure but not just for the green poison
but all viral infections however he is
unable to access it without his
briefcase and this was on Air Force One
when it went down the briefcase was in
the position of the true sons and they
were holding it in their HQ at the US
Capitol building president Ellis ordered
the agents to do what it takes to
cleanse the city of these hostile forces
and return his briefcase
however the division weren't strong
enough to be able to tackle this
challenge just yet first things first
they located the fault in the network
and restored power to the strategic
homeland division in there agents from
here they set forth clearing hostiles
and pushing them back to their
respective strongholds
upon removing the hyenas from the
district union arena the outcasts from
Roosevelt Island and then the true sons
from the US Capitol building the
division had now eliminated all hostile
leadership leaving affections in a state
of disarray but also they had found
Alice's briefcase
while the agents and the JTF celebrated
their progress towards regaining control
of the capital a force that have been
looking in the shadows suddenly made
themselves known
the technologically advanced private
military company called the black tusk
launched a full invasion of the city
landmarks and strategic points
throughout the city were quickly brought
under black dust control and it was
during this time that president Ellis
suddenly disappeared it was revealed
that the black tusk had been watching
the progress of the dollar flu outbreak
for some time including the actions of
the strategic homeland division division
agents soon found out that it was this
new hostile force that was responsible
for the shd network being taken down and
that they had been planning this
invasion since the outbreak first
occurred the black tusk head in very
quick succession completely undone all
of the progress that the division had
made up until now and wavered
the agents against all odds once again
fought through it was discovered the
president Ellis had actually handed over
the antivirals to the black tusk and
that they had been working together and
in fact had something to do with the
death of the last president they hadn't
put into power the antivirals were being
held at the black tusk tidal basin
headquarters the agents launched an
attack and managed to fight through the
technologically superior forces
regaining control of the antivirals
Washington DC is once again in a state
of mayhem with the three original
hostile factions although without their
original leaders fighting for control
and now a new more powerful faction
attempting to establish a new dynasty to
lead the country into a new era
prison else has been located he is found
to be hiding out at the presidential
retreat Camp white oak under heavy guard
by Black task forces the JTF
and the division assault the compound in
an attempt to arrest
Ellis and bring him back for questioning
unfortunately before they could reach
him he managed to escape his whereabouts
are currently unknown the division
agents then turn their attention to the
Pentagon they have received a
transmission from an agent close by the
agent was scouting the DARPA labs to see
if they had succeeded in developing a
perfusion bioreactor with this device
they will be able to produce large
quantities of the broad-spectrum
antivirals and start to distribute them
across the population however they
weren't the only ones looking for it a
large black task operation was underway
they were attempting to dig down through
the Pentagon and extract the bioreactor
but the division agents managed to put a
stop to this and turned killing dozens
of black task officers the perfusion
bioreactor has now been kept at the
White House along with the
broad-spectrum antibiotics tip towards
creating a cure requires the agents to
find someone capable of running such an
undertaking someone with experience in
this field
the division received intel on the
whereabouts of a former agent who was at
the top of their most-wanted list
Aaron keener has finally resurfaced
after disappearing months ago last seen
in New York City keener has made a deal
with the black tusk unit that is
stationed on Coney Island he is planning
on trading vitally treinen Co in
exchange for a favor that'll cool upon
at a later date [ __ ] Co is a
virologist that has ties to the creator
of the dollar flue dr. Gordon Amherst
the division saw this as a great
opportunity kina is the man behind
countless deaths of jtf and sh t agents
and the leader of the initial rogue
agent uprising Antron Inca is the
perfect candidate to run the bioreactor
the situation was too good to let slip
by a way that could be running into a
trap the division launched an operation
to rescue true ninka and cap Shekinah
despite heavy black tusk presence they
managed to extract the Russian scientist
to the surprise an old foe had joined
the fight the cleaners the black tusk
suffered heavy losses at the hands of
both the cleaners and the division
agents they were forced to retreat
a distress call was received from the
division command and lower Manhattan
City Hall has been attacked agents from
Washington make their way to New York
through video surveillance it has found
that a group of rogues led by Aaron
keener were the ones responsible the
attack had left the building completely
destroyed and contaminated by a new
unknown virus that keener had acquired
from the teletran Inc Oh before they
parted ways the hunt for Aaron keener
was on the division agents set up a base
in a local settlement called haven with
a local commanding agent fehlau got to
work compiling clues on Tina's
whereabouts with all that had happened
over the last few months in New York
with countless once loyal agents going
rogue faith in the division was at an
all-time low agents would have to regain
the trust of the remaining population if
they were to succeed one by one the
agents located and eliminated kinas
rogue lieutenants through each encounter
they found new clues in intel on Tina's
whereabouts including his plans to reset
society keener had set himself up on
Liberty Island his plan was to launch a
ballistic missile that was filled with
his new weaponized virus on Manhattan
the agents bought a theory and make the
way to the Liberty Island
but before they make it there they are
attacked by the black tusk who have also
learned of kinas location and are trying
to get to him before the division does
they sent ground forces to stop kina
including her Marauder class quadcopter
war hounds in a respect missile launcher
but the division agents managed to push
through and overwhelm their forces
it was now just the agents and Keena
even with his new more advanced shd tech
kina was no match for the division
agents they managed to destroy the
missile launcher containing the virus
and heavily wound kina he escaped to the
pier that his injuries proved too much
division agents caught up to him and
before they could stop him he activated
something on his watch something he
called his legacy
with his dying breaths he laughed at the
agents telling them that they have no
idea what's coming
before dying shortly after it was at
this time broadcasted through kinas
watch that division discovered that the
acting commander of the division in New
York Fela had gone rogue and was working
with the black tusk
before the events City Hall Kenner had
spent some time recruiting he was
building an army of rogue agent cells
each tasked their own mission
this group of rogues rule aligned
through kinas own version of the sh t
network called enna the first cell was
headed by an agent going for the
callsign Jupiter with their team of
rogues supported by the cleaners running
a distraction in Washington DC she was
able to secure a newly developed EMP
technology from a cargo plane that had
crashed on Roosevelt Island this new
technology was able to neutralize all
non rogue shd tech and completely remove
an agent's armor Jupiter's mission was
to capture this tech get it operational
and ship it out to rogue agents
nationwide this would [ __ ] the
remaining shd agents around the country
however the division was able to
overwhelm her forces and react faster
than Jupiter was prepared for on
Roosevelt Island she ordered the
cleaners to utilize all available EMP
jammers to put a stop to the fast
approaching agents but it was too late
the division pushed through the defenses
destroying the EMP s and found
themselves face-to-face with Jupiter and
eventually after a long battle the
agents put a stop to her plants killing
her in the process unfortunately for the
division this would be just the first of
a potentially large number of rogue
cells that the division would face in
the months to come
this has been a roundup of the division
two story covering the first year and
half of year two we know there is more
coming so I'll probably update this
video sometime in the future obviously
there's a lot more depth that the story
goes into and for more information you
can see a lot of these videos in the
description if you are new to the
division and maybe only started playing
with the division two came out I have
another video that covers the story from
the original game and how it leads into
the division two there should be a link
on screen now other words thank you very
much for watching and I'll catch you in
the next one Cheers
[Music]
you